[Music]
[Music]
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
lawyer
turned cancel culture survivor turned
candidate for senate from the great
state of missouri
mark mccloskey welcome to the reuben
report hey thanks for having me on
i'm thrilled truly thrilled to have you
on because
what you are doing right now by getting
into the game after the monster tried to
destroy you i think is exactly what
america needs
so i'm putting my cards on the table and
just saying that at the top as an
interviewer everyone knows the video
everyone knows the video we played it
already at the beginning of you and your
wife
when the black lives matter antifa
activists were outside of your house
and you have decided to run for senate
so before we do anything else let's
throw to the commercial
when the angry mob came to destroy my
house and kill
my family i took a stand against them
now i'm asking for the privilege to take
that stand
for all of us i will never
back down our nation is under attack
big tech big business the swamp in dc
are all working together to destroy our
god-given freedom
our culture and our heritage when was
the last time
a politician defended you defended
america
stood between you and the mob we need
defenders but all we get is dividers
every day they teach us to hate each
other
left versus right black versus white
rich versus poor
this is a tactic to destroy us but we
are all americans
we are missourians our nation our state
our homes are worth defending our
freedoms
are worth defending i can promise you
one thing
that when the mob comes to destroy our
homes our state
and our country i will defend them i
will never
back down all right mark why
why would you get back into the fight
after going through what you went
through
well you know what what most people
don't understand or don't remember
because the press didn't report it
because it wasn't good for their their
narrative
was that after the first assault on the
28th of june
the mob came back on july the 3rd with a
specific intent of killing us and
burning down the house
and it was now twice as many people as
it was in the 28th
and we had six navy seals and
10 secondary employment police and the
fbi light aircraft circling the house
and we had a standoff against a thousand
people
and that was a night that the president
gave his mount rushmore address and he
talked about
defending against marxist extremism in
the united states
well i didn't get to hear that speech
that night i was a little busy saving my
behind
um but i listened to it the next day and
the media
reported that as being the most divisive
speech a president could give
and i said to myself and i said to my
wife when the when this country is in
such a condition
where the media reports defending
against marxist extremism
as being divisive like we're supposed to
live together in harmony with the people
that seek
to destroy us and our way of life and
our culture we've got to do something
about it
so we just decided to put our lives on
hold and do everything we could
to to defend this country support the
president and so we went on the campaign
trail
and then when we're on the campaign
trail two things
one is every place we we we spoke we
found that people are just sick and
tired of what's going on in the country
cancer culture the poison of critical
race theory
the lie of systemic racism all backed up
with a threat of mob violence
people wanted genuine change and you
know we we had genuine change with with
donald trump
and if the election had officially gone
the way that
we had expected then then we'd have done
our task
we'd have gone back to being just
ordinary citizens but it didn't turn out
that way
and we continue to campaign on our own
after the after the election
continue to give rallies in support of
our constitutional rights and
our god-given freedoms and uh well
we found out the second thing and that
is that everybody that we ran into at
every alley there would be somebody that
would tell us
a tale of a personal miracle where god
had made a personal intervention in
their lives and it made a material
difference and
hoped their miracle happened and we
realized that that this was something
that we were obligated to do that that
we had to
to give back we had we found that we
we just decided that we had to do
something to save this country no matter
what we could do personally we had to do
it because this country is so close
to the end i said throughout the
campaign that
this was our last opportunity to save
our democracy that if we didn't reelect
donald trump
the left would pack the supreme court
nationalize elections
go for d.c and puerto rico statehood
eliminate the second amendment with just
judicial fiat
everything that has come true in the
last four months
and we used to talk about the erosion of
civil liberties but now there's just a
wholesale slaughter versus
several liberties and we also now have a
state
of what can only be described as
socialism where the government is now
paying people more to stay home and live
off the government fit
than to go out and work when i'm driving
around missouri these days and we do it
all the time now
every mom and pop shop every gas station
every convenience store
has a sign out saying hiring all
positions same here same here
find employees because employees can
make more money by sitting underdog
on the false promise of something free
from the government
but the government never gives anything
free what the government does
is takes your freedom in exchange for a
false promise
of a better life without having to work
and you know that that bill eventually
comes due
and no matter what the what this current
administration says
you're going to have to pay the bills um
yeah well eventually you either got to
pay the creditors or go to war with them
which at this rate who the hell knows
let's i don't want to
i don't want to dwell too much on the
original events but i i just if you
could just talk about it
from really from a personal perspective
you you live on a private
street that was gated and locked they
broke in
now you're trying to protect your house
and you know once we see these things on
tv
it almost becomes because of the reality
nature of everything it's almost like a
cartoon when people are watching it you
don't really realize
that these are real people in their home
that they own
their property as you said defending
their
property with their god-given right of
owning arms
can you just talk a little bit about
what it was like that moment when you
had to say to your wife
i assume you know we gotta we gotta get
the guns we're we're literally
threatened right now we and it takes a
little bit of background too because
uh 28 days earlier on june the first
night of june the first june the second
uh in response to the george floyd event
the
people that always are preaching their
moral superiority to us
decided their way to establish peace and
love was to burn down downtown st louis
and they they rioted and they looted
that night four police officers were
shot
uh police captain david doran was
murdered during secondary employment
about a half a mile from where i'm
sitting right here wow
in the ensuing three weeks the more and
more businesses got got looted and
boarded up
a little pharmacy around the corner from
our office which is just three blocks
from here
uh was broken into they they pried up
the steel rolled on doors
stole everything they could steal broke
everything they couldn't steal
so i asked the owner i said well did the
cops ever show up
10 hours after the alarm went off my
wife and i watched the 7-eleven in
downtown st louis
two blocks from the police headquarters
from the time the first brick went
through a window
people came and looted it empty threw in
fire
building becomes engulfed in flames
patti and i are watching it from from
our bedroom on a live helicopter feed
10 20 30 40 minutes
no police showed up no fire showed up we
looked at each other and said you know
when the fit hits the shan
you're out there and you're wild
lonesome and so that's the context when
we see this mob coming down the street
up three to five hundred of them six
flight
six lane road completely filled from
side to side
for as far as we can see and then all of
a sudden the gate bursts open right
and they start storming in now these are
the same people that have just burned
downtown and killed people and destroyed
millions of dollars worth of stuff and
you know the the liberal press would
would have me uh interrogate each one as
they came through the gate
now are you the good writer or are you
the best right right are you the
peaceful protester
yeah and by the way what's your race let
me see your birth certificate you
know all this kind of yes no
they broke down the gate and they
started storming in the first thing i
did was say
the two most racist white superiority
comments you say in the world i said
private property and of course these
people being communists
when i said private property that
inflamed them and they just came rushing
in
well my wife went in to call 9-1-1 my
daughter was with us that night too
she's 31
she'd come in from chicago for dinner um
she went in to call 9-1-1
i went around the first door i could
find and grabbed my ar which i had
staged because we'd heard there might be
a riot
and that went out in the uh on the porch
and i started saying
private property get out i probably said
something impolite like
get the hell out of my neighborhood and
then all of a sudden
thinking that paddy's still in the house
calling 9-1-1
all of a sudden she shows up in front of
me on the lawn
waving that dumb-ass little bryco pistol
over here and she never fired a gun
like but now i've got a problem because
i don't have a clean line of fire she's
between me and the
and the mob and if something bad happens
i don't
i can't put off a shot because i might
hit her i kind of like her you know i
wouldn't want to have to accidentally
put a bullet in her
and so now i've got to come out in the
front lawn and that's and that's the
the scene that everybody sees and that
32
second clip that's on all the news
that's the last 32 seconds
after the entire crowd has already
dissipated but there were people in
front of me
wearing body armor carrying weapons one
guy pulls two loaded magazines out of
the pockets of his of his
of body armor points them at me so i can
see this
they're loaded with with rounds clicks
them together and says you're next
sky standing next to him also with body
armor got a sidearm on
and he keeps engine closer and closer
and closer i mean these were not
peaceful protesters
these were people that were there
meaning business and afterwards
yeah well did you feel in some way that
your whole life had led up to that in an
odd sense i mean obviously you didn't
know that you were going to run for
senate just a couple months later but
you
you were prepared for this moment
they knocked on the wrong door yeah yeah
i mean i had been a very vocal
anti-communist my whole life i'd
i had been speaking and and
interestingly ali
has enforced and and we did a video with
him last week
but uh back and i was i was reminiscing
with him because we've known each other
30 years
but back when i was in college i was
lecturing against the sandinistas and
nicaragua
and daniel ortega and here it is all
these years later
the uh the san andreas are still in
charge of nicaragua daniel ortega is
still there
but now john kerry instead of
complaining about ali north doing
business with the iranians
now john kerry's doing business with the
iranians you know
in the world yeah something something
didn't go right in the course of those
three decades or so
one more one more question on the
original incident and then i really do
want to talk about what you want to do
going forward
can you just talk because i know so many
people are just so afraid of
the mob and i mean that literally and
figuratively can you just talk about
what it was like to see your name in the
media being called a white supremacist
and just all the awful stuff that you
had to deal with
and then we'll move on to sort of what
you're going to do going forward
well the good news is well i said this
the very first reporter
if i had been the senior partner at the
largest law firm in st louis
i would have had to apologize until i
was blurring the face and then resigned
my job anyway
the only reason i was allowed to go
forward with my life was that we're
self-employed
we're independent we're
transmission and nothing the press could
say was going to bother me one way or
the other
and this i think the second interview i
had was with
with chris cuomo and my wife advised me
not to go on a cuomo show you know i
knew what a snake
was anyway but the very first thing he
says is how do you like being the face
of white resistance
right and what a what a load of horse
manure right
i had no idea what race people were when
they're coming in
i saw an angry mob they're coming down
the street and and you know
you've got to understand that this was
not a benign event
you've got three people screaming at the
top of their lungs
chanting beating on drums hammering the
street with sticks and then they burst
in
and yet you know that they've just
killed people you know that they've
burned
businesses down they've ransacked and
now they're right in front of you and i
mean we're talking
40 50 feet in front of the house and
coming towards you
this is not a benign event and i i had
no expectation of surviving if i tried
to defend myself
i had no expectation of surviving if i
didn't but by god i wasn't going to go
down without a fight
but we held him off no one got hurt not
a shot got fired
you know right now there are people i
think more than 36 of them
sitting in solitary confinement cells
for the offensive trespass
at on the u.s capitol none of the three
to 500 people that trespassed
in my yard saw a day in jail let alone
months of solitary confinement
so it really is a different way the the
system works if you're a republican or
if you're a democrat
yeah all right so with that in mind you
are running as a republican as you said
you you've been a conservative
uh what would you say are like the main
the main factors
in in how you view your your political
life
well the major thing is that we just
need to reestablish
who runs this country the declaration
of independence is pretty goddard and
concise you know that we have
rights and doubt by god including
life liberty and pursuit of happiness
and i i always start my speeches
with a recitation of the declaration of
independence
but i always stop with the line and
amongst these are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness then joe biden made a speech
the other day
and in his speech he said this he
started talking about the constitution
you know joe has a hard time getting
sentences out but eventually he says
we the people are the government not the
people
he said we the people are the government
and i i
popped up on my computer the actual
written transcript
of his speech and that's actually what
he said and so since then
i've been adding the next line to my
speech and that is that to secure these
rights
governments are instituted amongst men
deriving
their just powers from the consent of
the governed
and that's what my campaign is all about
to remind those folks up in dc
that the government exists by the
consent of the govern
and they've ignored that they think we
exist subject to the
whatever privileges they think that they
will dribble down to us whatever they
think we deserve
but the power resides in the people and
we need to pull it back
what do you think the main issues are
for the people of missouri right now i
mean i i understand
sort of the broad freedom aspect and the
and the federal government's
you know encroaching and all this stuff
but are there sort of granular on the
on the ground issues in missouri that
you think are unique to that state
well yeah you know of course uh taxation
is an issue
of course spending and creating fiat
money that just
weakens the economy and and devalues
everything gas prices i mean we're we're
in agricultural state
and imagine how much more expensive it's
going to be
to plant and harvest this year
by 50 the last four months um and and
the border crisis
i mean once again being an agricultural
state when you've got
hundreds of thousands of work eventually
millions of illegal aliens pouring in
what's that do for the economy of states
that would otherwise
employ american citizens to do that same
labor
it is devastating and once again it's
two things it's devastating to the
economy
and it dilutes the legitimate voter
roles of
everywhere including including your
state in california and mine here in
missouri
and that's done intentionally i mean
there's no there's no accident involved
in any of these things um and then and
then fair trade i mean
uh once again uh we've spent decades my
entire life until
donald trump got elected president
letting the rest of the world take
advantage of us in trade
and now we're right back there and can
you believe can anybody in this planet
believe
that joe biden is allowing the russians
to build their pipeline
while incredible cancer the excel
pipeline in the united states
what massive hypocrisy who does this guy
work for
well it ain't him making the decisions i
think that's clear has trump or anyone
from the trump campaign reached out to
you because it's
in some ways it's like man he should be
just out there with you tomorrow
well the and then no you know obviously
we would we would love to have the
president's endorsement
but we've had no contact with him
directly i sure i sure would like to
because
uh you know he did more in four years
despite
being blasted by the media every single
day and having nothing but negative
reporting on him and you know every time
he blew his nose it was there was a
reason to
to impeach him and yet he did more in
four years than anybody else had done in
the last 40
and now to see it all wiped away all
that progress destroyed
by uh uh you know who's running the
country
i don't know it certainly isn't mr i'm
gonna hide in my basement
so i don't have to tell anybody what i
believe in
how's the coverage been for you the
mainstream coverage in missouri and
nationally you know the second i saw the
ad i
said to my guys get him on now and you
guys
you know that's when i know it's a real
campaign because your people immediately
responded
unlike what's going on here in
california where caitlyn jenner's people
completely m.i.a so to me that's just
that's just theater your people
working on it and and here you are but
how's the mainstream coverage been for
you
well i'll answer that first part first i
mean how why i'm on here today is i got
a text message
from a grassroots supporter of mine
saying hey
dave rubin said that if you want to be
on a show he's got an open invitation
so i contacted my campaign manager and
said get me on dave rubin's show today
i think i think we had traded there we
had emailed just as your guys had
emailed us something like that yeah it's
fantastic i mean that's what it's all
about that's a beautiful thing
but we've got two major papers in
missouri we've got well on the in the uh
um big cities we have two big cities
we've got kansas city and we've got st
louis st louis post dispatch for the
kansas city star
um and if i were adolf hitler or joseph
stalin i'd have gotten
more favorable coverage okay
internationally what are they saying
what are they saying just the same old
stuff
the uh just the uh gun waving uh st
louis couple who who's only only
qualification for political office
is that they pointed guns at peaceful
protesters i mean that's
that's the uniform line i uh i was
interviewed by an ap
reporter this morning and he had written
that same big lie in his article
two days ago so i brought for him today
a photograph
of the blm protesters stepping over the
gate that they had smashed down
despite the fact that the the fake news
mainstream media
constantly reports that they were
walking peacefully through an open gate
and you know that mainstream media has
has little interest in
little or no interest in actual truth
they have an agenda
but we know that and that's not going to
bother us yeah and i can sense already a
groundswell of online support for you
which is obviously fantastic
i guess i guess we can wrap with this
which is what would you want
anyone else watching this to to know
about standing up for yourself and why
you gotta do it because not only did you
do it you then decided to double down
and go into the flames again and and no
matter what happens here
i think it's an incredible story well
here here's what i've been saying to
everybody and i'll say it until
until i die now or until the country
goes first
um that is you can no longer depend on
the government you can't
you can't hope that big tech or big
business is going to save you
if you don't like critical race theory
get get involved
elect a school board that will prohibit
it if you don't like
unconstitutional mandates coming down
from your mayor or county executive
vote them out put in real conservatives
that'll respect the citizens rights
if you don't like what's going on in
your state capitol throw out the rhinos
throw out the democrats vote in real
conservatives every
single citizen needs to make a personal
commitment
to taking back their freedoms vote in
people
that you can trust and vote if they
don't live up to
your trust and you know if if people
want to help out if people think we've
got a right idea
go to mccloskeyforsenate.com donate
whatever you can
five ten bucks there's a real grassroots
campaign
you know that the media is going to dump
on us the left's going to come down on
us like a ton of bricks
i suspect maybe even some of my
republican cohorts
will have less and complementary things
to say about us
but i don't care we're here to represent
the people of missouri
and if the people of the missouri want
to have somebody who's
not subject to intimidation who has no
strings attached
who will do everything i can and will
never back down
and when i go to rallies i get a general
outpouring
of similar belief everybody knows that
our rights our freedoms are given to us
by god
that when the founders of this country
wrote the declaration of independence
and the constitution and the bill of
rights they weren't creating
privileges for us they were merely
recording in paper
the rights we were born with as human
beings made the image of god
mark well said man i wish you the best
of luck i i'm so impressed by the story
and this is exactly what america needs
uh we're gonna link down to your senate
campaign below so hopefully people will
jump over there throw you a couple bucks
if they can
and i wish you luck and i hope we cross
paths and maybe if i make it out to
missouri
i'd love to join you on stage i'll get
the crowd going for you
all right i sure appreciate it awesome
thank you so much
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell